it is really killer man and he is murder
is what his doing is killing the
children's and the woman's that's what I
can say about him I've only been in
Israel 23 years but you're doing a
wonderful job to protect the country to
warn us and to keep us informed as much
as you can
now in the cast of sticky mud acquainted
cinema seem that silicon is waha Zack
most of the bed till I thought no cutlet
for Leia Jews open up still walk it and
know I am or CSC learn a lot funny but
on Alma de los del C del if tota by
other T's Elliot urge to me denote shall
establish my lab seat and negotiate a
lap should be said of gamma the Sharma
Schmidt settlement volume money phoneme
Cal I'm a Odessa be call it can about my
Shalu as they must be a llama
Palestinian my skin I wish that your son
is burned and killed and I want to know
how you feel you are not a hero you're a
criminal and the American mr. Obama is
also your partner because both of you
are one coin with two sides Masha -
Clayton anomic aphasia the air meets
local opposite of chaos devil Zetas
officials a retaliatory Michelle abusive
Hanabusa god bless Israel I'm from New
Zealand and I'm a lover in supporter of
Israel
I believe support Israel
you killed the children in Gaza and now
you so you say support Israel
well we support you must go home when
those Rockets are coming you understand
that they're trying to kill you
simply because you're you and so we
support it and it's a shame that a lot
of a lot of our country and sometimes a
lot of time our president is even not so
much behind it so come on man take his
holy shit the shopping motherly tree so
we say
children Binyamin Netanyahu a second
Michigan shoe Fatah bmd fascist Ocean
Avenue Dean I met was $50 you know the
Metallica gamla so to ba- us into well
we have to get him LM can ii Melissa
Lehman who highly such a way survey
million Muslim of the symphony McManus
new law integer worth to talk us through
what Madonna Moses Wharton Mariama
Hashim Solomon lowered try to balance on
official tough locomotor demo Madonna's
tree in Samira Yarmouth she their
Americana Don of Salado Veeru
you